we are taking calls today we're taking
calls early because of the Thanksgiving
holiday uh that will be thursday and
friday so we're taking calls early 617
830 4750 is the number we'll take our
next caller name and where you're
calling from i'm i'm nick roberts i'm 16
and from minneapolis okay great to hear
from you neck what's on your mind uh so
as I'm firm like Candace home state
right I know a lot about him and he's
done and him and Trump probably not very
good so if you have to unless president
who would you choose personally I think
I'd probably pick uh Trump but like I I
feel like both be pretty bad by shape
into probably more things on that week
adds I'm careful who you you're saying
if I had to if I could choose to either
keep Trump is President or make up Mike
Pence the president which would I choose
yeah oh absolutely done wrong absolutely
Donald Trump I I think that I'll did
this is one of the main issues right now
with people already talking about
impeachment of Trump that makes Mike
Pence the president and that is very
dangerous right i mean yeah it's true
that already right-wing ideologues
establishment ideologues are are making
their way into Trump's cabinet and
advisory roles but maybe the fact that
Trump is slightly less traditional at
least with some of the positions that he
touted during the pre the campaign will
hold off the lunacy of the sort of
evangelical hard religious Rite of Mike
Pence that's my concern Pat with
everybody talking about an impeachment
of Trump then you've got pence well I
also think that Donald Trump has shown
size that it signs that he's willing to
compromise at times and work with
Democrats and I guess he was a Democrat
for most of his life but then you have
my pants on the other hand who uh
supported gay conversion therapy and
mandatory funerals for aborted fetuses
so there's a lot more concerning things
his way yet there's no doubt about I
mean for me the answer is super clear
get if you could say you could wave a
magic wand and make pence the president
instead of Trump I wouldn't do it I I
just think that that's a big mistake
thanks so much for the call great that
you're engaged at 16 years old
absolutely love that and did you'll be
able to vote in a couple years so good
that you're paying attention